on a profité du cs 2019 pour lancer un
nouveau format audio qui s'appelle le
360 reality audio accrochez vous bien il
ya un prototype sur le stand d'enceinte
speaker 360° réalité audio attendez vous
à ce que ce soit la prochaine révolution
en termes de format audio
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui on est à new york à central
park
j'ai une petite balade pour se donner de
l'air froid la fumée qui sort de la
bouche au froid d'enfer meilleure façon
l'hiver toujours est parfois bon et
quelques jours vous savez j'en ai
beaucoup parlé j'étais au cnsad gas et
l'otan se faire un petit retour par à
new york
tranquille vous profitez néanmoins et
j'ai encore des choses à vous raconter
notamment concernant la visite sur le
stand de sony un énorme stands
j'adore à chaque fois pour l'instant
complètement incroyable se disent à
taddei donc pas dérogé à la règle
un stand juste gouffre avec plein de
choses hyper cour regrette d'un mois
qu'ils peuvent smartphones mais compte
en termes de délais en termes d'audience
pour révolution saut à 360 degrés il y
avait énormément de choses sur le cinéma
sur netflix ça c'était vraiment un truc
de ouf
ce que je vous propose c'est qui
retourne et je vois les grandes
nouveautés les grandes tendances qui
vont décider cette année et au repas lab
se dit très prochainement parce que je
vais le haut
baupin yves world congress mwc à
barcelone
ou soldes y sera présent aussi avoir
plein de choses hyper cool et a par
contre par un smartphone à l'écart
[Musique]
la star
m
ce cas
alors laissons les normes stand de sony
au cs un truc complètement incroyable
avec plein d'activités plein sera testé
ce soit les appareils photos que soient
les télés huit cas que ce soit les
casques à réduction de bruit il ya
énormément de soldes
et franchement c'est hyper
impressionnant loïc on te voit bien que
ça votre petit peu oui bon loïc c'est
quoi les nouveautés de sony cette année
au surf ben écoute pas mal de nouveautés
comme chaque année près s'attend à ça
avec une marque comme sony pas mal de
nouveautés les alors qu'avant nous
qu'avons nous qu'avons nous par ici et
venez celui de suspendre un bon marché
au final c'était de l'intox jetons
qu'est ce qu'on a ici en a le nouveau
téléviseur 8 15 h dr de chez sony voit
ses ordres c'est énorme énorme au sens
propre comme au sens figuré une grosse
bête immonde il en détaillant 498 pouce
de gros mastodontes de plus de 100 kg il
n'y a pas de date de disponibilité n'y a
pas de pluie de communiquer beaucoup de
personnes attendent et des lancements
sur le huit cas de la part de sony
durant ce salon
ils ont eu lieu le week à oui c'est bien
mais c'est pas pour tout de suite ça on
n'est pas sûr du coup du formao l'aide
on est vraiment sur du fromage lcd on
n'est pas en mesure de répliquer cette
vibration de la dalle qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure mais aussi de par la taille de
par la nature de la dalle en tête on va
mettre qu'on a lancé si tu te rapproches
un système et sa peine c'est un petit
frère de l'acoustique surface qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure tu t'appelles empêche le
l'acoustique multi audio donc en fait
c'est des haut parleurs qui en fait
qu'on tourne directement les craintes
qui
qui vont dans la direction du spectateur
et qui permettent en même temps de
ventiler la dalle parce que mine de rien
le mastodonte qui chauffe un peu
et donc voilà donc la qualité d'image
est assez est époustouflante dans sa
tente pas ce que ce soit des téléviseurs
donné on parle évidemment de premium
d'un nouveau standard d'un point vue
technologique avec les jeux de olympique
de les jeux olympiques de 2020 en ligne
de mire c'est des choses qui vont
arriver peut-être d'ici cinq à dix ans
pour le grand public parce que tu
portais des choses qu'on retrouve dans
les foyers dans des causes et des
certainement l'idée c'est évidemment de
commencer à construire cet écosystème
aussi pourrait pour tous les clients
professionnels dans les chaînes de télé
les producteurs à hollywood mais aussi
les chaînes en europe
donc oui c'est clairement l'avenir donc
on va voir ce que ça donne
vous avez un petit corner avec aillent
bosser le chien intelligents connectés
de sony
voilà c'est pas toujours son petit effet
assez rigolo ici on parle de réalité
virtuelle avec forcément le casque de
réalité virtuelle de sony il ya
forcément beaucoup de vert bon et si
vous avez des simulateurs de conduite
gran turismo forcément c'est sur la
playstation 4 ça et regardez moi ce
grand écran
c'est absolument incroyable ça donne
vraiment envie de l'essayer
alors ici vous avez la partie télé écran
oled on est sur l'a4 cas c'est un écrin
d'une très belle marque qui s'appelle
sony elle pas mal pas mal pas mal pour
commencer c'est un écran
la technologie oled mais la vienne plus
que ça bien puisque ça donc l'oled
pour rappel c'est ce qui ce qui est ce
qui casse un peu tout en ce moment sur
le marché
c'est vraiment la grosse tendance est
une énorme croissance en france sur les
écrans de grande taille comme on le
précède on la leur et
qu'est ce qu'on a ici on a en fait le
renouvellement d'une gamme déjà
existante qui s'appelait auparavant line
of women on appelle ça la g9 donc celle
aux enfers disponible de 55 à 70 7
pouces ok cool et surtout cela intègre
une technologie qui est plutôt sympa que
certains d'entre vous devrez peut-être
déjà connaître qui s'appelle
l'acoustique surface dont la musique se
passe qu'est ce que c'est
c'est en fait une ancienne centrale qui
est intégré à l'intérieur de l'écran se
situe pour que dans les contes indigne
ou pas il ya différentes du haut niveau
est différent haut parleurs qui sont
intégrés à la fois en haut et en bas de
l'écran 1 à 5 entre d'accord et donc
c'est la dalle oled qui vibre et qui
aimait un sont directement de l'écran
donc une prouesse technologique qui a
pas de haut parleurs en fait autour du
téléviseur et plus besoin d'eux
debard 200 en fait la qualité sonore est
suffisamment bonne pour profiter d'une
expérience cinématographique de qualité
à la maison et quoi d'autre cet âge et 9
du couvent y arrive en 3 tailles et mes
petites nouvelles l'an dernier on avait
parlé de l'assistance google qui allait
devenir disponibles sur le téléviseur à
jour cette fois ci le problème est réglé
et cette gamme arrive directement avec
l'assistant nouvel intérêt
là vous avez un écran 77 pouces et du
oled c'est assez incroyable elle lumière
est vraiment belle les couleurs sont
complètement incroyable
les contrastes sont hallucinants c'est
franchement très très beau là vous avez
les 30 98 pouces c'est assez hallucinant
et là regardez c'est la série netflix
perdus dans l'espace alors c'est space
en anglais j'adore vous avez les la
combinaison et là vous avez les normes
robot qui est toujours aussi flippant
vous avez donné casque à réduction de
bruit de sony alors je les ai déjà testé
j'en ai un à la maison c'est le sony
alors le notre choix compliqués je m'en
souviens jamais c'est le wh1 1000x m3 le
résultat est franchement coup d'ailleurs
j'invite aller voir ma vidéo de test on
est une marque d'audio on a lancé un
monstre dans l'industrie qui s'appelle
le casque mix marque 3 way il ya
quelques mois je crois que tu as eu
l'occasion de tester récemment gelé dans
mon sac à dos voilà voilà j'adore je
promets qu'il n'est pas payé pour dire
ça je ne suis pas payé je vous le
confirme et du coup bon donc voilà
l'héritage vraiment sur l'audio sony a
évité évidemment que ce soit sur les
enceintes les barres de son les casques
et on a profité du cve 2010 9 pour
lancer un nouveau format audio qui
s'appelle le 360 reality audio accrochez
vous bien
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ce sont
en fait enveloppant 360 degrés qui
passent sur les côtés derrière les
oreilles à j'en passe et des meilleurs
et l'idée c'est vraiment de travailler
avec
avec les producteurs avec nos confrères
de chez sony music et les artistes
surtout les artistes les créateurs pour
produire ce nouveau format du futur ça
va être une open platform qui va être
disponible à moyen et long terme en
streaming
nicolas on en train déjà de développer
une gamme de produits et 360 qualité
audio qui va avec il ya un prototype sur
le stand d'enceinte speaker 360° réalité
audio c'est donc affaire à suivre
on verra ce que ça donne mais attendez
vous à ce que ce soit la prochaine
révolution en termes de format audio
d'accord ok alors du coup c'est quoi ces
deux là c'est du son stéréo qui est
transformé en 360 en c'est du sang qui
est produit 330 360 degrés qui a
enregistré en fait de manière
tridimensionnel d'accord et donc on a
également signé un partenariat avec
like live nation qui est une grosse
entreprise de divertissement aux états
unis qui gère pas mal de salles de
concert et d'artistes dogbatsé et l'idée
c'est d'aller enregistrer ses concerts
pour ensuite les diffuser entre 160
réalité audio dans un homme âgé coup
alors qu'on produit qu'ils y en a le x p
12 donc la nouvelle enceinte nomade de
chez sony qui coûtera 60 euros qui sera
disponible début du printemps
ok je n'avais donc voici voilà le modèle
exprimant différents coloris qui a fait
partie de cette gamme d'enceintes
nomades extra basse d'accord très
populaire chez sony qui a aussi de
nombreux grands frères dans la même
famille saunier pour habitude de nous
surprendre avec des produits toujours
design assez assez sympa ici on a un
concept pour le moins original à savoir
une enceinte en horaire la s2 sera
disponible pareil dans les prochains
mois un tarif de 6,1 euros est en fait
comme vous pouvez le remarquer le sont
sans directement du haut parleur au
niveau du pire est donc un produit assez
minimaliste design clarté sonore plutôt
élégant sans oublier toute la partie
vidéo toute la partie caméra alors là
bon vous avez quand même un très très
bel exemplaire de tout ce que vous avez
ici c'est des champions ça va de la
caméra professionnelle jusqu'à dix
caméras full frame pour venir filmer
pour faire d lopp force que vous voulez
des photos enfin les trucs qui sont
vraiment hallucinant clients n'oublie
pas
les audiophiles les cinéphiles avec
également des produits un petit peu plus
at 25 on va dire un peu plus un peu plus
dick
mais voilà les lecteurs blu ray d'accord
il ya un hic suisse en marque deux qui
vient d'être lancé avec tous les toutes
les compagnies lité de division et c'est
d'accord donc à ça ainsi qu'également
des nouvelle barre de son est là vous
avez tout une table de montage pour la
création de contenu principalement pour
des professionnels
vous avez même la caméra pro 6 cordes et
spider man derrière toi des lost in
space du netflix un rose qu'on essaie de
montrer ici c'est un peu bel héritage
saunier en termes de divertissement
le fait que c'est un groupe énorme avec
du sony music du sony pictures des
artistes et acteurs des studios
hollywood
bonton cambon
peut-être sans jamais parler mal des
concerts mais ne marque unique au monde
alors que tout cet héritage toute cette
infrastructure rencontre ici
on it up oled de nos confrères du
professionnel pour ce qui s'appelle
l'écrit master qui sont utilisés dans
les studios de production etc les
réalisateurs ici on compte y en a
ensuite
les caméras de production à hollywood de
la gamme signer haletant donc il ya du
woody allen il ya james cameron le
prochain avatar est filmé en saunier de
gens le savent mais c'est une réalité
en fait on montre comment mais voilà la
production eu lieu directement à travers
une caméra sony et comment on amènera
directement dans vos salons dans mon
petit appartement à paris ou ailleurs
vas-y oz chanson c'est dans l'idéal sur
un téléviseur sony
évidemment merci beaucoup loïc kalkuhl
gras de solutions ip data centres chez
sony une fois de plus
regarde ça attentivement et puis on se
revoit tu seras plus relevé cette fois
pas j'y serai j'y serai je fais en sorte
de faire
un petit goût sans parler de plein
d'autres produits google
voilà pour cet épisode américains du
jour entre vegas new york peut voyager
dites moi ce que vous pensez des
nouveautés de sony de cette année au cs
à las vegas et je vous dis abonnez vous
restez connectés parce qu'on va partir
au mwc très prochainement c'est fin
février à barcelone
j'espère qu'il fera plus chaud qui s'ils
proclament dernière voit que w7 tombé de
la neige
allez savoir dites moi tout ce que vous
en pensez puis je vous invite à les
consulter mais différentes vidéos parce
que j'ai pas mal de choses sur le cv est
pas mal d'actu peu mal de nouveautés et
c'est hyper intéressant
voilà et si vous avez des questions
suggestions interrogations vous pouvez
marquer tout ça en bas en commentaire
soyez sages prenez soin de vous regarder
ça la regarde on se dire ces mots là
derrière europe central park des
building à perte de vue
voilà ça c'est beau ça caille allez on
s'embrasse ciao